this war is lost though it's better find  the deepest pit and cower there until  all this over how can you expect us to  follow you against the dead walkers in  their general huh  I always knew it would be you there is  not enough space inside you for two  souls that demon wants your body  it will control you more and more until  it has replaced you completely I have  traveled this world and lived amongst  these peoples it's elves it's humans and  I have witnessed the truth of their milk  today I thought with dozens of new  brothers and sisters will arise from  listen to me we have no chance against  the deadwalker army no matter what  powers you have  one with the power to get us food why  does no resist  you